one of the problems and it is a problem
with the oil and gas industry is the
issue of flaring and so if given oil
well is not within proximity of a
natural gas pipeline then the producers
will flare the natural gas that's coming
out of the ground but that's bad because
you're just wasting a valuable resource
and you're emitting CO2 because you're
burning this gas for no reason so what
Bitcoin miners particularly in West
Texas that I'm familiar with
I know some of them they're they're
locating in areas where there was a lot
of gas that was being flared and they're
saying hey we'll use the flip we'll use
the gas that we were going to burn we'll
run it through a turbine or
reciprocating engine will produce power
and then we'll mine Bitcoin with that
juice and so I think this is great I
mean you know they're producing
something that has value from something
that has no value and was from creating
pollution so I think that's a big win
foreign
guys bang bang I've got Robert here with
me Robert you are one of the foremost
experts in electricity uh and also other
energy uh forms and markets and I
thought a great place to start our
conversation today would simply be on
this idea of electricity rich and
electricity poor and how there is such a
big difference in terms of access to
electricity and also based on geography
what people are able to do with
electricity in these various locations
how do you think through the importance
of access to electricity and what really
is the defining factors for making
somebody electricity rich or electricity
poor
well thanks Anthony thanks for having me
on uh you're right this is the defining
disparity in the world today as you look
at the world now where some eight
billion people there are roughly three
billion people almost 4 out of 10 people
in the world today live in places where
per capita consumption of electricity is
less than a thousand kilowatt hours per
capita per year so we're talking about
the amount of electricity it's roughly
equal to the amount that is used by
average kitchen refrigerator in the U.S
so you know when we look around the
world at nearly all of Africa Miss South
Asia these are places where people live
in dire energy poverty but in particular
dire electricity poverty and and why do
we care well if you care about women if
you care about girls who care about
women's rights this is the key issue
because electricity as I've said many
times and I talk about in my book
electricity frees women and girls from
the from the the stove and the wash Pub
and the uh and the pump I mean they you
know if you don't have electricity you
have to carry water if you don't have it
you gotta you know all of these chores
that we take for granted that women have
to do in the home if they don't have
electricity they're effectively slaves
to to the home home uh home tasks so
electricity is the most important and
fastest growing form of energy in the
world and it's the biggest challenge we
Face globally in terms of bringing
people out of the dark and into
modernity in your opinion what are the
obstacles that need to be overcome to
get electricity to all seven and a half
eight billion people in the world what
are the things that we could do to kind
of accelerate that adoption and make
sure that people in developing nations
have as much access as people in the
developed Nations
Ellen that's a it's a really good
question Anthony it's a hard one to
address because you need civil society
and fundamentally and and in writing my
new book a question of power and my new
documentary juice we went to Beirut and
we were also in Puerto Rico and you look
around the world at where countries are
racked with corruption the grids reflect
that corruption you have to have a
strong Civil Society for electricity
grids to work people have to pay for the
power you can't just give it away I mean
you can for a while but you but
electricity grids run on money you have
to keep investing money you have to buy
the fuel you have to upgrade the
generators you have to continually
Monitor and and repair uh the the the
poles and the wires this is a con
electric grids need continuing
investment so if the society is corrupt
and we saw this after this fall of
Saddam Hussein in Iraq Saddam is a bad
guy I'm really a bad guy but he kept the
lights on and nobody stole electricity
when Saddam was in power because if you
got caught bad things were going to
happen but once Saddam fell and the U.S
you know we were in this kind of
Coalition a power theft skyrocketed and
so today Iraq is a basket case when it
comes to its electric grid and the same
is true in Beirut same we saw the same
in India people steal electricity so
creating that Civil Society is not
easily done and it has to be done by the
people in the countries that where they
live and it's a very difficult task
that's the key one so but then after
that if you don't have the you don't
have that Civil Society you don't have
the capital and then if you don't have
the capital you can't build it build out
the grid so these are tough challenges
and then there's the issue of challenges
of fuel nuclear power whether it's coal
gas these are other issues but they the
first issue is the corruption issue what
have you seen in some of these areas you
mentioned Iraq being one example where
they basically had electricity there
wasn't a lot of electricity theft and
then it kind of reverts backwards but
obviously things like natural disasters
we've seen Puerto Rico specifically but
many other places around the world that
have some level of development some
level of connectivity and they kind of
get thrown backwards sometimes decades
worth of progress is erased by some sort
of natural disaster are there any
lessons that we can learn from what
happens in those societies once they've
kind of gotten a taste of the
connectivity but then are kind of thrown
backwards
well you know it's good that you
mentioned Puerto Rico because we were
there and we filmed for juice we filmed
in Puerto Rico and remember
these are American citizens on American
soil now they're a colony effectively of
the United States there are what is the
right word it's they're not they're
obviously not a state they don't have
representatives in in the in the House
of Representatives
um but they don't what we saw they got
hit by two hurricanes in a row well
that's difficult right in any kind of
circumstance but you need hardened
infrastructure you need uh power poles
there is a steel power steel Towers
instead of wood we saw this in south
Louisiana where you know they're hit by
hurricanes regularly there well if you
use wood power poles instead of steel
ones or concrete ones they're not going
to last and that's a pro again that goes
back to the capital issue which requires
these continuing infusions of money to
make sure the grid has Integrity but
natural disasters are I mean they're
hard I mean I've seen it I saw it in
south Louisiana people will use local
you know small generators to get the
power they need if they can't rely on
the grid
another place in the world where we've
seen a huge impact is Russia's invasion
of Ukraine now it isn't just electricity
it's natural gas it's oil there's it's a
bunch of these different forms of energy
um but it seems like uh there's a lot of
confusion because headlines will read uh
tons of sanctions against Russia but
then if you look at the dollar
denominated uh trade with Russia it
appears up in that same year and a lot
of that has to do with just spiking
prices and things like that how do you
as someone who pays a lot of attention
to various energy markets and kind of
the adoption of these uh fuels evaluate
what is actually happening right what is
going on in that sector of the world
when it comes to natural gas oil and
mainly uh electricity as well
well let's talk about Ukraine first
because this is a complex and multi uh
multi-faceted challenge
um and what is Russia doing and what
have they begun doing since really they
started last October started attacking
the Ukrainian grid and this was a way
that you if you want to if you want to
kill modern society what do you do that
you attack their electric grid and so
the Russians have been slowly degrading
the Ukrainian grid and there was a very
good article in the Wall Street Journal
a few a few days ago talking about that
you the alignment and I my some of my
personal heroes or electric lineman I
love those guys right the people who
turn the wrenches who get up in those
bucket trucks and all kinds of weather
that these were you know they were being
lauded by the ukrainians as their Heroes
because of what they were able to do but
the Russians are slowly degrading the
Ukrainian grid and making it harder for
uh ordinary ukrainians to get along and
to have heat in their homes and the
lights and this is this is a corrosive
effect on society and that will continue
I think we've seen that the Russians are
going to continue these attacks on their
on the Ukrainian grid and then that
becomes a problem because then you don't
have the necessary Transformers you
don't have you run out of wire you run
out of the polls you run out all of
these things in the supply chain then
become more difficult and then we
haven't talked yet about nuclear power
and then in the zaparisia nuclear plant
that the Russians are now claiming as
their own that plant has been shut down
it's in safe operating mode not at no
big danger of an accident there but this
is what the Russians are claiming as one
of The Spoils of War
um and they want that plant for
themselves and so the the adamantly
pro-nuclear but it again as a I talked
about before requires Civil Society you
need strong governments with strong
systems and people that are trained and
well trained that can run nuclear power
plants and that's no easy task
if we then bring it here to the United
States what's fascinating to me and I
know something that you've covered
before is this idea that uh renewable
energy is meeting immense resistance in
Rural America so it's an idea that is
kind of uh received a lot of popularity
and support in the coastal Elite cities
and inside of our academic institutions
and then when you kind of meet reality
whether it's in the plains of the
Midwest if it's kind of in the Deep oil
and gas sector of Texas or elsewhere
people kind of aren't as excited or they
may actually be anti-sum of these ideas
or not believe that it's actually
possible to do this what has been your
experience in trying to unpack what's
going on between the ideas and the
theoretical and then the reality on the
ground especially in the rural parts of
America
well this is one of the key challenges
Anthony is that we we hear a lot of
promotion renewable energy and it pulls
very well you look at any of the polling
data large majorities of Americans say
oh we love wind and solar but they don't
want to live next to these big projects
and so the what I see is very clearly an
urban rural divide in this regard
um and I'm not a partisan I'm not a
Democrat I'm not a republican I'm
disgusted right but the Democrats are
very much Pro Renewables right and they
and the Democrats get the majority of
their votes in the big cities you can
see this on any of the Electoral College
Maps you know
um but in Rural America there is
widespread resistance to the expansion
of wind and solar projects I I maintain
the renewable rejection database I
started collecting this data in 2015.
why because is the famous industrial
analyst W Edwards Deming said in In God
We Trust all others bring data so I
started collecting the numbers right and
then now I've done it for not going on
nine years
here's the punch line last year alone in
the United States there were 79
rejections of solar projects 79 and of
those more than 40 of them were in the
state of Ohio where you had more than 40
townships rejecting wind or solar
projects or saying they are not welcome
here either wind or solar or both it's
happening in Iowa it's happening in
Indiana in Illinois and all across the
central part of America but really it's
from Maine to Hawaii this is a story
that was never reported on the New York
Times or big media outlets in 2019 there
were 200 people arrested on the island
of Oahu protesting a wind project 200
arrested so this idea that wind energy
and solar are clean and green yeah yeah
yeah but they require massive amounts of
land and that's the key issue and it
can't be overcome because of the low
power density of wind and solar and so
this is one reason why I've been
reporting on it and of course the wind
and solar guys don't like that I report
out they don't like it they want to
Discount the rejection database but the
numbers are the numbers they're not my
numbers they're the numbers
one other aspect of this that
um I was not aware of until uh the
United States pulled out of uh
Afghanistan was uh there are these mines
where minerals and metals and magnets
and all these other kind of components
that end up being put into various types
of Technologies or physical products
that are supposed to be helping
accelerate the adoption uh of renewable
energy there are mines all over the
world obviously throughout different
African countries Afghanistan China Etc
but as I dug into Afghanistan
specifically the Taliban essentially
came under control of this mine or they
came into control of the mind and as I
dug deeper and deeper I started to
realize well China has very deep control
of a lot of these mines as well
sometimes in the country of China other
times they have partnered up or financed
they have a lot of debt on some sort of
mining operation or Logistics moving the
metals minerals and uh other components
to kind of their destiny Nation
are we just at a point where even if
everyone accepted renewable energy it
would be hard to actually build enough
of the physical products because the
components are either too expensive or
too inaccessible for kind of the western
world and the United States of America
specifically
well I'd restated as saying that the
this idea around the energy transition
which is the phrase we hear all the time
is that the energy transition the the
metals minerals and magnets that are
that are DOT that are required for the
energy trans China has a dominant role
in nearly all of those
um I just spoke in Houston yesterday
about this the the department of energy
last year released a report on neodymium
iron Boron magnets these are the high
strength magnets that are doped with
dysprosium and terbium to make them work
better in high temperature but these are
the critical magnets used in electric
vehicles and in wind turbines China
controls more than 90 percent of the
global production of these neodymium
iron Boron magnets but you look at this
there was a report that just came out in
the last few days from the International
Energy agency you look at electrolyzers
to produce hydrogen you look at wind
turbine blades in the cells the electric
vehicle batteries electric vehicles
themselves China again controls dominant
dominant market share in all of those
and further back to your point on the
mining and the processing the same is
true for Rare Earth elements I mentioned
dysprosium and terbium neodymium
lanthanum these that market is also the
Rare Earth elements also controlled by
China and the growth of areas like if
we're processing of things like Cobalt
copper lithium nickel again China has
the dominant position in in not just in
current production but in the projected
production of those Metals so there's
nothing free right you know there's no
such thing as Milton Friedman said
there's no such thing as a free lunch
and this idea that oh we're just going
to shift away from the hydrocarbon based
economy which we've been doing now for
more than 120 years and go to something
else
this is going to take a lot of time and
a lot of money and we have to be very
clear about the supply chain risks and
what this means in terms of the US and
China and our long-term relationship
with China I'm not a China Basher China
is going to look after China but we have
to be very clear about this
there's another idea that you've
popularized and I've seen you talk about
this idea of natural gas to nuclear as a
way for the United States to address a
lot of different problems what exactly
does that mean natural gas to nuclear is
that just we need the full array of
options from an energy standpoint
I I typified this way Anthony I say this
is the No Regrets policy if we're
serious about decarbonization so global
warming and climate change this is a
real Challenge and the way I put it is
climate change is a concern it's not our
only concern so if we're going to be
rational about how we go forward and we
think about what we're going to do with
regard to reducing emissions what is the
what are the best ways to go about that
for 13 years I've been saying the same
thing end to end natural gas to nuclear
why because both of those sources are
lower no carbon they're abundant the
Technologies are well known and the and
the ability to grow them and and allow
them to scale up is is there is real
potential there there the amount of
natural gas and new discoveries in the
Mediterranean just in the last few weeks
are offshore Egypt massive discoveries
of new natural gas same offshore Africa
the world is Awash in natural gas but we
have to drill for it the technology of
nuclear energy well-known well-developed
the Chinese the Russians the South
Koreans the United States the French
there are a lot of countries that can
deploy nuclear at scale so if we're
serious about reducing emissions
we need to be serious about natural gas
and nuclear because Renewables cannot
will not be able to scale up to the
degree that we need to if we're going to
make a serious Den in global CO2
emissions
so what fascinates me about you and why
I wanted to talk to you was uh kind of
two different components that are
related the first is that you have been
a very outspoken critic of the United
States goal to reach energy Independence
you basically said that is not feasible
to actually accomplish on top of that
you I believe testified but for sure
have publicly criticized both George W
bush and Barack Obama two different
sides of the aisle uh for many of the
energy policies that we're pursuing
specifically around using renewable
energy to eventually get to a point
where the United States could be energy
independent and serve all of those
energy needs that we have
as you approach this
is there any path to where the United
States could actually get to an energy
Independence or is it just that the
renewable energy path that is being
pursued can't get us there hey guys
what's going on I hope that you're
enjoying this conversation but I wanted
to interrupt for a quick second and tell
you about a brand new conference that
I'm hosting on March 4th at the Miami
Beach Convention Center the event is
called lyceum Miami and tickets are
completely free for anyone who wants to
come I'm bringing together many of the
most popular guests from the podcast
over the last couple of years some of
the guest speakers that we've already
announced are people like Vivek
ramaswamy from strive asset management
or Delian and Mike Solana from Founders
fund Chris Williamson from the modern
wisdom podcast Cody Sanchez from
contrarian thinking and billionaire
Christian ogrenmeyer among many others
I've got a number of amazing surprise
guests as well some that you definitely
will not expect and others that come
from walks of life that you will be
scratching your head as to how how I
even got them to show up but come check
out lyceum Miami on March 4th the lyceum
was a public gym in Athens Greece where
people used to come together talk about
ideas and debate topics that were
important to society I want to meet
people in person in real life once again
after three years of a Hiatus from real
life events and so I'm hosting the event
and as I mentioned anyone from anywhere
can come to this event completely for
free all you need to do is go to
lyceumiami.com and you'll be able to
pick up a free general admission ticket
make sure you claim your ticket in order
to get in through the doors lyceum Miami
is going to be a great time so come
check it out come hang out with me many
of the popular guests from the podcast
and other like-minded individuals lyceum
Miami March 4th Miami Beach Convention
Center I hope to see you there all right
let's get back into this conversation
well the latter I would agree there's no
way that we can rely solely on renewable
energy to get us to be independent as I
talked about China the supply chain with
China is one that this is going to take
decades to change we can't suddenly
begin producing these these magnets some
metals and minerals at the scale that
the Chinese are now we can't do it in a
couple or three or four years we can't
do it in a decade it's going to take
multiple decades but I think the issue
that go back to the energy Independence
this is a this is a marketing slogan we
are interdependent in the world today on
on all kinds of different things we
could talk about tennis rackets or shoes
or beer or wine or you name it we live
in a global economy and yet this idea of
energy Independence it goes back even
back to the 19 1973 in the OPEC oil
embargo where you know politicians are
saying well we should be independent of
foreign oil okay well I get that and now
we've talked about this this same issue
now for almost 60 years but we are still
not energy independent in the U.S we
export a lot of crude oil we import a
lot of refined products we export a lot
of refined products and so we live it in
particular when it comes to the oil and
oil market and now increasingly in the
natural gas market we are interdependent
in the world forgive me
um we're independent in the world and
that's not going to change I mean and
and well it shouldn't because look at
the you know energy independent well if
we were energy independent we wouldn't
be able to send natural gas to Europe
right so we we you know we have to the
the reality of a global integrated
economy is real and it's particularly
real when it comes to energy and energy
Supply chains I recently spoke to a
gentleman uh Bill Perkins Bill Perkins
is a natural gas Trader pretty well
known uh in the poker World a number of
other uh Industries and one of the
things that uh he brought up was uh
actually many of the actions of the
United States in the Russia Ukraine
conflict uh have caused more
inefficiencies we've seen backups and
storage around the world we see places
saying I'm not going to use that
pipeline but instead I'm going to put it
on a ship and then I'll just sail it
around uh you know and get it there from
a from a different Geographic uh
approach what is the the kind of
measurement that you could give us in
terms of how inefficient is this entire
Logistics and energy Market becoming or
is it actually becoming more efficient
over the long run with some short-term
hiccups where there's inefficiency
introduced like is the is the trend that
is becoming more efficient or is the
trend that is actually becoming less
efficient over time
and that's an interesting question I
hadn't thought about it in those terms
but I I put it this way I think that the
molecules that we are producing whether
it's natural gas or particularly propane
my friend Chris Wright his favorite
hydrocarbon is propane right because
it's easily transported under a standard
temperature and pressure you can use a
cooking fuel you can use it as a v you
know a transportation fuel as a process
of chemical you could turn into
chemicals I think that market we see it
in the in the maturation the very fast
maturation of the the global LNG Market
remember it was only about six years ago
the U.S began exporting LNG at all and
now the US is one of the world's biggest
suppliers into the of LNG into the
global market so I think the short
answer would say would be that the
market is becoming with the energy
Market is becoming more efficient
because those molecules are finding
homes faster than they ever have before
and the U.S is playing a bigger role
fortunately in this uh in this
Marketplace because of the Shale
revolution has fundamentally changed how
the U.S and interacts in This Global
Market for those that are listening LNG
is liquefied natural gas which is
relatively new to to the market uh
Robert another thing that you've talked
about which uh I gotta admit this gave
me a good chuckle because uh as someone
who is native to the internet uh I love
someone who can come up with an idea
that just probably absolutely really
really upsets uh their critics and one
of the things that uh you have
criticized is this whole idea of the
safety of birds or Wildlife protection
laws uh and what you explicitly call out
is that there are oil producers and
Electric utilities that have been
charged and find under the migratory
bird treaty act for killing birds right
it is no good it's bad there's rules
that prevent them from doing that and if
they do it they are end up getting fined
Etc but you wrote this article in the
Wall Street Journal which uh is so
important and deemed so important that
it's literally on your Wikipedia page
with this excerpt that says yet there is
one group of energy producers that are
not being prosecuted for killing birds
wind power companies and wind powered
turbines are killing a vast number of
birds every year a July 2008 study of
the wind farm at alamant past California
estimated that its turbines kill an
average of 80 golden eagles per year the
study funded by the Alameda County
Community Development agency also
estimated that about 10 000 Birds nearly
all protected by this act are being
whacked every year at Al Lamont ten
thousand Birds is a big number
why is it that there is such a different
treatment to the different companies
when it comes to just Birds let alone
other things
well thank you this is a key issue for
me I'm a long time bird watcher I'm
proudly a bird watcher I'm an
Outdoorsman and I you know this is
something that gives me great joy and a
whole lot of other people and the bird
populations around the world numerous
studies including a recent one by
Cornell have documented dramatic
declines in the bird population around
the world and yet these wind companies
are allowed to build these wind projects
and in fact I wrote about a published a
piece last year Newsweek the biggest
Renewable Energy company
producer of renewable energy in the
world next Air energy built a wind
project in the middle of known Golden
Eagle habitat they were warned three
times by the fish and wildlife service
not to build the wind project where they
built it they built it anyway and they
got fined under the migratory bird
treaty act they should have been charged
criminally under the golden eagle and
golden eagle protection act they weren't
but they paid a fine to the federal
government unless I think it was memory
serves something less than 30 million
dollars
but they did it on purpose Anthony I
mean they did it on purpose they
knowingly went in an area where they
knew they were going to kill Eagles and
they did it anyway and so this just
grinds my grinds my gears as my late
brother John Bryce said grills my cheese
how I mean in what other industry would
be allowed to do this except this
supposedly clean energy business it's
outrageous it is totally outrageous and
the way the wind industry responds is oh
well it's only a few or oh cats kill
birds cats don't kill golden eagles cats
don't kill bald eagles I mean this is
this is a farce and yet this industry is
allowed to get away with murder and it's
not just Birds it's bats as well and
this is one of the other parts here that
I think is critical because
in fact the impact on bat bat
populations may be ultimately in terms
of ecosystem impacts greater than the
impact that these these wind turbines
are having on on birds bats are
important pollinators and insectivores
and so we've seen in numerous studies
from uh in Canada and all around the U.S
in fact it studies showing that these
the the number of bats who are being
killed by wind turbines may be greater
than the number of birds being killed
and this is a real problem because bats
generally have very slow reproductive
rates there are only flying mammal and
so this you know this this impact on
wildlife and this excuse that oh it's
only a few or well you know global
warming or climate change well damn it
no this is not okay we need to think
about these impacts first and it's one
reason why I'm so adamantly pro-nuclear
if we're serious about reducing
emissions we need small Footprints and
and nuclear energy has the highest power
density of any form of power generation
we should should be doing that instead
of littering the landscape with these
giant wind turbines
why is nuclear uh so toxic as a topic
why is it that no one wants to approve
the building of these new facilities or
uh it whenever is brought up uh by
anyone who appears to be in the
mainstream kind of conscious or or talk
track they just immediately discount it
and say like that's not an option let's
go back to the renewable conversation
how long do we have today
I mean the the demonization of nuclear
energy by the left by what I would call
the these in the NGO corporate climate
industrial complex and their push for
Renewables instead of nuclear it goes
back decades and it has been the Sierra
Club for instance and the natural
resources defense Council the natural
resources defense counsel by the way has
an annual budget of over 400 million
dollars a year they bragged about the
closure of the premature and foolish
closure of the Indian Point Nuclear
Plant in New York City or just outside
of New York and what has happened since
the closure of that nuclear plant
emissions in New York state have
skyrocketed and so have consumers bills
because now they're more reliant on
natural gas
so this demonization of nuclear is not
new it's been part part of the playbook
for these uh for these ngos I don't call
them environmental groups because I
don't think they're Environmental Group
they don't call them green I don't think
they're green if this has been part of
their playbook now for decades and
they're not going to change
um but if they're serious in my view if
you're serious about climate change and
numerous climate scientists have made
the same point you can't be serious
about reducing emissions reducing
greenhouse gas emissions and dismiss
nuclear energy in my view if you're
anti-carbon dioxide and anti-nuclear
you're pro-blackout well Anthony I am
adamantly
anti-blackout
so am I
um one of the industries that uh has
forced people to become uh much more
informed about energy is Bitcoin mining
I don't know if you know anything about
uh the mining industry uh or have any
thoughts there uh just given its
intersection with so much of the energy
conversation uh both in the United
States and internationally
sure let me just add one quick point on
the nuclear thing if I may just jump
back to that because
Anthony I think that the conversation
has shifted I think that we're and I'm
seeing it here in the U.S we see it in
the in the extension of the Diablo
Canyon Nuclear Plant in California we
saw it in the extensions of the nuclear
plants in Illinois Byron and Dresden
that there is a new Cadre of younger uh
climate activists pro-nuclear people uh
Maddie hilly with the campaign for a
green nuclear deal Mark Nelson with
radiant energy fund Paris Ortiz wines
a big group of people who are
campaigning to save and our existing
nuclear plants and build new ones and
it's a different generation I'm 62. it's
a younger generation that is carrying
this issue forward and I think that
we're seeing some momentum on Capitol
Hill with a push to reform the NRC to
add you know Federal uh funding and
support for new nuclear power plants so
that's very hopeful I think and
something I wanted to just make clear
before I talked about Bitcoin and
Bitcoin mining it's clear Bitcoin mining
is you know it's an enormous power our
consumer there are some miners here in
Texas that are using when they're
locating in West Texas they're using
low-cost power when when wind energy is
is you know blowing when there's a lot
of wind energy in West Texas mining
their you know mining Bitcoin and
ethereum and other other
cryptocurrencies when they have cheap
power and then shutting them off when
power prices go up
um so there's no doubt that this you
know what Bitcoin mining essentially
you're just arbitraging the price of
electricity and turning it into crypto
and so they're looking all over the
world for low-cost electricity because
they're looking for that Arbitrage and
so they're finding it some in Texas of
course in China and you know other
different locations around the world
where you have hydro or or so on but you
know I'm not opposed to bitcoin you know
I think it's interesting I've seen you
know crypto mines in in Iceland we we
visited some and featured them in our
film juice so it's an interesting
industry is it real is it crypto real
yeah it's a longer discussion I mean we
don't have all the time for that today
I'm sure well what's fascinating uh I
think for us to discuss today because
the audience will definitely have their
opinions about real or not real is um
mining as a ability to stabilize the
grids Texas for example when there was a
number of different uh blackouts or or
problems uh miners basically were
getting paid to shut off they did it all
of a sudden you get the stabilized grid
and I think a lot of people in the
Bitcoin Community kind of hold those
events up as an example as to we should
have minors everywhere in the United
States they can help to stabilize these
grids is there flawed thinking there or
do you think that that has some Merit
I I don't necessarily agree with this
word stabilize I think that it's what I
I how I typify it is that the miners are
able to use power when power is cheap
and then shut down when it's dear and
that good for them I mean you know in
that regard they're not any different
kind of in a macro sense than maybe
other big industrial users so uh I I I I
don't see any problem with that right
you know people you know people have
always are finding different ways to use
electricity and data centers are massive
you know Google and Amazon they have
effectively created their own grids with
their own backup power generators and
they're doing it because they need five
or six nines of reliability right 99.999
on time or online uh rates of for their
customers make sure they don't go down
so the Bitcoin miners you know look
they're going to locate where they they
find an opportunity where they can find
cheap power and then you know but
they're I I like the word stabilize I
think they're they're using the grid to
their best advantage and so am I yeah
um
I have and I say that because I have
power I've solar panels on the roof of
my house right I have I have eight and a
half kilowatts of solar panels so half
of the year I get I don't pay anything
for my electricity to Austin Energy so I
use the grid when it's convenient for me
so in some ways I'm not I don't know are
you stabilizing the grid yeah okay there
you go if the Bitcoin miners are
stabilizing the grid then so am I
um another topic that uh is frequently
talked about in both the Bitcoin world
but I think also oil and gas uh is this
whole idea of the flare capture uh and
the ability to actually uh monetize that
uh energy source right there uh on site
what's your thoughts there or have have
you kind of uh seen anything that people
should be aware of yeah I think this is
really something that's very positive
um one of the problems and it is a
problem with the oil and gas industry is
the issue of flaring and so people are
not familiar if the given oil well is
not within proximity of a natural gas
pipeline then the producers will flare
the natural gas that's coming out of the
ground and this is particularly
prevalent if natural gas prices are low
and they're low now and they're about
less than three dollars here in the US
and the latest Henry Hub prices
um but that's bad because you're just
wasting a valuable resource and you're
emitting CO2 because you're burning this
gas for no reason so what Bitcoin miners
particularly in West Texas that I'm
familiar with and I know some of them
they're they're locating in areas where
there was a lot of gas that was being
flared and they're saying hey we'll use
the flip we'll use the gas that we were
going to burn we'll run it through a
turbine or reciprocating engine will
produce power and then we'll mine
Bitcoin with that juice and so I think
this is great I mean you know they're
producing something that has value from
something that has no value and was from
creating pollution so I think that's a
big win
for a Layman like myself who knows just
enough about the energy industry to uh
be dangerous it feels like that is the
one thing that everyone oil and gas
politicians entrepreneurs bitcoiners Etc
all kind of look at and say that seems
like a good idea and then once you kind
of get outside of that flare gas uh
capture uh and use case uh there's a lot
of debate right like it there becomes
much more questions and debate uh but
that flare gas capture seems to be the
the winning strategy to get a lot of
different types of people groups and
perspectives all to come to the table
and say okay I can get on board with
this is that your experience as well
yeah I think it's you know it's a simple
I mean this would in poker you literally
call it a lay down hand right well you
know look we're we're preventing the
waste of this resource and we're
creating something of value from it and
we're making money at it and and so I
think it's a
win-win-win-win I don't know how many
wins you can claim there but I mean this
is a really positive development and the
next step would be then for or some of
this other gas that's being flared well
could we turn it into other products or
could we turn it into power and put it
back on the grid or could we turn it
into you know something else we haven't
thought about yet but I think this is a
very positive thing and it's some you
know just entrepreneurship at work this
is what it's what people and
entrepreneurs do they look for that what
my friend Porter Bennett calls the with
a fat margin and he said then they find
that fat margin and it gets squeezed as
more people find that uh that
opportunity and exploit it before I let
you go one of my favorite questions to
ask reporters uh authors of books or
people who uh have the uh the ambition
and uh and the heart to create
documentaries is what are the stories
that are most interesting to you in the
world right now like what when you think
about uh things that you're interested
in or things that are developing what
stores are you paying attention to
I like that question you know on my
podcast the power hungry podcast I
always ask people what are they reading
and what gives them hope those are my
closing questions but
as a and that's I think of myself as a
reporter right I don't you know I've
written six books I've made a
documentary I'm a podcaster I do these
other things I'm doing a lot of public
speaking but I think I'm just at root of
reporter and what what do I respond to I
respond to people
you know I and I think that one of the
strengths of our documentary juice is
that it's a people movie and so why do I
maintain the rural rejection database
why do I care about these people in
rural America because I love those
people you know and I've met some of
them I'm you know these these claims
that oh wind energy is green well what
talk to some of the people that have
wind turbines built near their homes and
they're suffering because of the noise
pollution from these wind projects and
it is noise pollution I've met these
people I've been in some of their homes
so I care about them and I care about I
care about those human stories and those
are the ones that I want to tell I mean
you know there are a lot of policy walks
and a lot of policy stuff to me what
really resonates and what the stories
that I really respond to are people
stories and humans and uh um working on
another documentary called Burning Down
The Grid and which we're really going to
do some of that and talk to people who
are you know in in that are on the
they're being affected by uh low quality
electric grids the spread of Renewables
Etc
what has been the most surprising thing
over your career when it comes to
electricity in the energy markets
another good question
well you know I'll answer a bit in one
way we went to India for when I was
reporting on the book and on my latest
book a question of power and when we
were making juice and I think the thing
that surprised me there was the absolute
abject poverty that I wasn't I I thought
I knew poor I thought I knew poverty I
didn't know what that was until I saw it
in India the level of poverty
um but I think that's one answer to what
surprised me I think the other is
Ingenuity and the thing that that I'm I
meant maybe it's a different not
surprised but maybe it gives me Faith or
gives me hope and that we are smart and
we're figuring things out and I'm very
hopeful for nuclear I'm I'm very
clear-eyed about the challenges for
nuclear power in America but I'm also
seeing a lot of opportunity and
entrepreneurs who are looking at this
market and saying how can we build a
better smaller faster lighter denser
cheaper reactor and deploy it at scale
and so
I wouldn't necessarily say that's
surprising because I've had a lot of
faith in the human spirit and
Entrepreneurship but that that is
gratifying and one that I'm I'm
continually uh impressed by this
entrepreneurship and this the level and
the depth and the amount of people and
number of people that are pursuing these
different opportunities like to be
talked about with the Bitcoin miners
locating and using flared gas for for
power
question of power electricity and The
Wealth of Nations is the book that came
out in 2020 uh there it is right there
there it is on your screen there you go
tell your friends tell your neighbors
you don't have to read it you just have
to buy it
you buy it on your Kindle I make a
better royalty so there you go amazing
all right my last question for you is
after this book what's the single best
piece of feedback you got from a reader
foreign
readers are will I get a good I guess
I'll answer it this way what gives what
heartens me what what motivates me what
keeps me going because I I work hard you
know I travel a lot and what may what
keeps me going is that people respond
and they say Hey you know I really like
what you said there or you know I'm
pleased you're covering this or or
people in Madison County Iowa saying
thank you for covering the controversy
in our County in our fight against
Berkshire Hathaway and Mid-American
Energy and the encroachment of these
wind projects that that is something
that I mean I take to heart and keeps me
motivated and uh you know what fuels my
my passion for this business and I have
a lot of passion for you know energy and
power it's my purpose it's my focus it's
uh what I plan to do for the rest of my
you know my as long as I'm long as I'm
able to work that's what I'm going to do
amazing well anyone who has not read the
book yet I highly suggest they go and
they check it out uh Robert where can we
send people to find the other things
you're doing the podcast than any other
platforms online that you think would be
helpful sure will I moved a substack
lately and had great fun there I have
just a recent piece that I published
there called the billionaires behind the
gas bands which has gone viral I've been
pleased to see that so I'm on sub stack
Robert
bryce.substack.com uh of course the
power hungry podcast is available on
where I'll find podcasts are found I've
written six books I'm easy to find on
the interweb but I have a website
robertbrice.com so uh but yes Robert
bryce.substack.com if you please
awesome I uh I appreciate taking the
time to do this I think that uh the work
you're doing is incredibly important and
I always appreciate someone who's
willing to think for themselves and kind
of say what they think so uh keep up the
great work and we'll definitely do this
again in the future I think I really
appreciate it Anthony great fun